welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Joker
cementing the Clown Prince of Crime is
comic books best villain once more I
thought I'd give a full character
breakdown on Gotham's most infamous
rogue throughout this video I'm gonna be
going over everything that you need to
know about the Joker as well as what
media you need to check out for the best
stories on the villain there will be
some spoilers here and whilst I won't be
discussing any major plot points of the
new Joker film there will be some of the
overall arcs touched upon here so if you
don't want to know anything then I
highly recommend that he turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
Joker cast your mind back to 1939 comic
book writers and artists Bill Finger and
Bob Kane have just created Batman a hero
who stands as a darker version of
Superman and who has become a big
success though the Dark Knight is more
than capable of taking down a
superstitious and cowardly criminals
he's yet to meet his match so the two
young creators joined by Jerry Robinson
come up with an incredible foe for his
debut entry in the pages of Batman issue
1 released April 25th 1940 Joker is
introduced to the world and things would
never be the same again
based initially on Conrad bites
character in the 1928 film the man who
laughs Joker was a sadistic and criminal
mastermind that smiled gleefully through
his murders over the years mirroring
Batman the criminal has taken on several
different incarnations that are all
equally as fascinating as each other
when the Caped Crusader was played for
Laughs in the 50s due to the comics code
Authority Joker became a prankster in
the 70s when things took a darker turn
for the gotham vigilante the Joker too
became more violent and aggressive and
throughout the decades however Batman
has appeared the clown prince has
murdered him this runs deep on a
fundamental level to showcase that
Batman and the Joker are two sides of
the same coin
Batman represents order whereas the
Joker represents chaos
and the two characters are heavily tied
into one another though DC had never set
in stone the Joker's true origin story
one thing has remained constant
throughout every incarnation that we've
had the Joker similar to Batman was born
out of tragedy however whereas Bruce
Wayne walked the path of good
potentially due to his resources and
wealth a poor struggling Joker decided
to turn to a life of crime my favorite
origin story of The Joker comes in the
seminal graphic novel The Killing Joke
by Allen war in which we see a
down-on-his-luck
struggling comedian have his wife and
unborn child killed by a malfunction
toaster this completely random event
massively changes the characters life
and after he's forcibly drafted into a
criminal act Joker is stopped by Batman
and falls into a vat of toxins as
chemicals which bleaches his skin white
his hair green and sends him insane
though the origin story that we see play
out in it could be the way that the
events that led to his creation happened
the character also states that he
prefers to leave his origin story as
multiple choice and therefore his true
past remains completely enigmatic in
Batman 1989 Joker takes the form of Jack
Napier and Simha the aforementioned
version falls into a vat of chemicals
emerging as Gotham's most unstoppable
super villain in 2008 though we never
learned his true origin story it is
believed that the Joker is an Iraq war
veteran suffering from PTSD and he uses
his masterful tactics to hold the city
to ransom in 2016 Suicide Squad he's a
ruthless modern-day gangster that pretty
much runs the underworld of Gotham and
has had many victims including Batman's
closest ally Robin in the 2009 teen
movie Joker
Arthur flack a struggling comedian who
lives in poverty dons the mantle due to
his circumstances and causes an uprising
and Gotham against the rich whatever the
story though Joker is the ultimate
unreliable narrator and you could become
completely caught up in his origin story
only to later learn that this never
happened and that the characters simply
imagined it all of the different
versions over the heirs have told
different tales about a man who similar
to Bruce Wayne had one bad day that
on how you look at it either made him or
broke him Batman was able to overcome
this perhaps due to his support system
whereas the Joker who probably felt
isolated fell deeper into darkness
whatever way you slice it though both
Batman and the Joker are products of
Gotham see in the most recent telling
Gotham is a completely corrupt
environment and one that lets the rich
get richer whilst the poor get poorer
the tight grip of finances causes the
city to slash medical and social care
and thus Arthur Flagg played by Joaquin
Phoenix struggles to get by whilst
keeping his mental state in check he
suffers from delusions and ultimately
causes an uprising in Gotham that
similar to the dog Knight Rises causes
Gotham's wealthiest of all its
masterfully told and it beautifully asks
the question is this flex fault or is
society built in such a way that a
character like the Joker emerging is the
only logical conclusion in other
iterations of the Joker he arrives after
Batman rather than before and showcases
the effect that the Dark Knight has on
the city for example in the Dark Knight
trilogy the fact that Batman dons a mask
in order to fight criminals forces them
to do the same in order to have some
anonymity and thus this causes a rise of
mass criminals throughout the city in
order to level the playing field The
Joker himself not only carries out
several mass murders but he also seems
to relish it
appearing insane though whether this is
all an act is up for debate and over the
years many have arrived at slightly
different conclusions though throughout
the decades his sexuality was rarely
touched upon with him pretty much being
deemed asexual and Batman the Animated
Series the Bonnie to his Clyde was
introduced with Harley Quinn a
psychiatrist that he led astray Quinn
and Joker have been in an extremely
toxic relationship over the years that
showcases that Joker doesn't really have
any empathy for anyone around him he
severely beat Harley and know in recent
telling she has left the character
there's always the chance that he will
woo her back The Joker similar to Batman
carries an Arsenal with him at all times
including giant guns electrified rings
and a lapel flower that sprays acid on
command like Batman he has had his own
cars planes and more over the decades
and whilst he is unable to match the
Dark Knight physically from time to time
he definitely has a weapons case that
can compete the Joker over the decades
has appeared in some absolutely
incredible stories that all stand the
test of time to this day
Batman 1999 is brilliant the Dark Knight
and Joker are phenomenal but there's
also other entries that are definitely
worth checking out such as the
aforementioned Killing Joke Arkham
Asylum by Grant Morrison the man who
laughs which we tells his first
encounter with The Dark Knight Batman a
death in the family in which the
character brutally kills Jason Todd
death of the family which is sort of a
love letter to The Dark Knight and
Batman endgame in which the Joker takes
down Batman and the Justice League in
brilliant fashion if you can only read
one though I highly recommend that you
check out the Dark Knight Returns it's
an awesome closing of the book on the
character and is outstanding from
beginning to end in addition to this it
can't be overstated just how much Mark
Hamill did a fantastic job with the
character in the animated series as well
as the Batman Arkham games and I highly
recommend that you pick up the boxer if
you want what my opinion is the
definitive portrayal the Joker no matter
the telling really is an outstanding
character and his legacy will no doubt
outlive us all as of October 2009 teen
Joker is the only comic book film to
ever get an Oscar due to he pledges
betrayal and the Christopher Nolan film
The Dark Knight though there are rumors
that Joaquin Phoenix will to be
nominated for his depiction the
character is one of the most
recognizable icons in pop culture and
safe to say that he is as loved as he is
feared acting as the perfect opposite to
Batman the Joker is an incredible
character and can be molded in any way
to fit any story whether he's The
Laughing buffoon or the maniacal mass
murderer The Joker has an appeal to him
that keeps fans coming back for more and
more it really can't be overstated how
brilliant that he is and in my opinion
he's the best villain ever created now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the Joker and if you agree with me or
not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the new geography or and
wack in Phoenix which would be linked at
the end I got over everything that you
need to know about the film and give my
interpretation of it so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want
more if you want to come chat to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books that make sure you follow me on
Twitter at definition whitey
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this I also
just want to let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on Joker
in the comment section below the winner
will be chosen at random on October the
15th and the blue arrow be shipped out
from the end whoever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like it subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition that
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care
[Music]
[Music]
you